I lost maybe about like 40 iPhones
whoever had my phones like have all my
lyrics like my first album is oh so now
I learned to not like save anything
before like I don't save numbers I just
know numbers by heart so if I ever get
like lost sending Ravi I it was stuff
hello it's a boy Eddie watt and rival GQ
is amassing the most essential thing I
have on me is my wallet one of my first
father's I had like when I became very
well a little bit on this when they
first started doing like the hook own
link like hands and I was like my thing
like I used to like hanging out knows I
guess it was cool back then but I never
got rid of it I still use it every day
it was really special about this item is
I keep it a letter for my daughter here
so his daddy be safe on the block
because we love you and we need everyone
to see it to be safe at all times I
don't really use a lot of things in my
wallet
except maybe my debit card yes uh my
license I'm pretty handsome guy there's
me the next is such a thing I have on me
iPhone 10 x max X next or 10 xx the big
boy so this is basically my third one in
the last three months the first one
happened instantly like I took it out of
the case like in the Apple store
like I could take that there than the
guy was gonna leave it and then I put it
in my pocket and I forgot to like put in
my pocket and I jumped on my motorcycle
and when I went over a speed bump it
just literally like maybe a half of mad
and above they was like yo get insurance
I'm like now I'm gonna need it and then
I had to go back and I got this one with
his shorts so the next essential item I
have on me will be some 1/2 kilo Newton
carrot protein pretty heavy is like
five-and-a-half pounds six pounds with
that have you seen my last GQ video but
the jury then you remember this chain
being a kilo and a half smaller and it
was diamonds everywhere this is like my
everyday sort of like a prize to myself
it's just me like value to me you know
like they don't have to be shiny and
sparkly some people don't even think
it's real and that's like the best part
to me and then maybe like you know like
my son get older you wanted anything
I just wonder like I'm never ever gonna
do it like I got rid of a lot of jewelry
but I brought a lot more juries but this
is one of those items I've never got
over those the next essential item I
have is I want to say is that everyday
thing but it's definitely like a party
starter for me and like when I go like
do for for me shoes are like host events
gotta have to remind you know everybody
knows runningboy 1738 like I I don't
know I'm not really the one that drinks
at 17:30 mozzie the one that drinks out
temporary I prefer to be yourself you
know I mean it's the 1724 actually but
it doesn't sound as cool as everything
video like 1724 no it's not catchy
so doesn't work I have a good story but
you know I don't know how to how laws
work so this is definitely a party
started essential for me and I prefer
this over like most other when X
essentially is definitely like half of
where is essentially the air pops
absolutely greatest invention I don't
know it's like titles to me personally
this is the best thing here for me
at first I thought it was a scam it's
like this is gonna fall out so you do
step like out the door and then you
gotta go get some more $400 and it's
gonna be no but not like daily sometimes
I don't remember that they and some
phone
then like I was livin air start tingling
it was not the best day like that that
was not a good filler I don't suggest
anywhere try to it
air pops never heard of them go get you
a page so my Nexus into is something I
actually got into when I became very
well I wasn't really into like different
food I like to smell their things I just
once I had like so good Irish springs
soap I was good hey this right here is
one of my favorites cloud person and you
can tell that guy use this [ __ ] this is
not it comes with me everywhere you can
see I'm not in select that alcohol-based
perfumes or come over it's like a laser
the skin it started like sinks of it
well I don't like strong strong strong
things I like the kind of cool oh yes
how about the cloud pusher that well my
next essentials are all day essentials
for me and my compadres my homies my
boys that bros I've been talking about
backwards since chop queen
what I will I've been a smoking stuff
out of backwards a little louder I'm
from New Jersey most people already know
that both in New Jersey but I'm from
Paterson New Jersey and then Paterson
maybe when I was like 15 or 16 like
backwoods you just kind of like an
eight-pack so this is like for three
dollars to two thousand five six and now
they'd like to know us and maybe if you
come to me a hat and I think it's $18
this might be partially mouthful but
backwards
I've arrived and have risen in price so
if you're not financially stable to pay
$18 for five back I don't suggest you
stop smoking so my next essential that I
have here is it's not really like
everyone but I kind of got into it like
2017 that did like a fashion show that
philipp lahm
and i never see somebody like unwrinkled
a shirt so fast like like just blown
away so then I just went steamer crazy
like I brought all kinds of steamers I
brought like a steamer that should put
like the shirts and you can put like
five shirts in there zip it down it was
almost close to my mouth I sold it yeah
you'd be surprised how many people who
love steamers like yeah it is like it's
like the world's best thing like yeah
let me show Stan Fatih steamers this is
the on the go this is the plug it in
before work and just take it off
hey bro it sure it's pretty good esteem
him fatty well my Nexus Oh - that never
leaves me ever like ever ever that's my
area this is my first GI a certified
diamond ever purchased
there was a twenty eight thousand per
ear it's like the most expensive to
items ever bought in my life they don't
drive anything
it was two earrings
I lost I also got video shoot the dudes
I here let me clean Jerry
so I was getting my Jerry clean and I
put everything on the dresser and like
it was just a lot of people just going
back and forth from there this hunger
for my Jerry on everything else was
there except my airman so I'm like how
the hell I'm gonna act all 70 people who
did they see one airing people live in
people coming back people jumping in Oh
grace out of it like it was just like it
was pretty bad yeah but I had a show me
show so that was all good I mean I can't
actually where to Eric that one's
anywhere like my son split this air when
his birth it was a movie that came out I
don't really know like maybe 19 I do
something called money talks but they
like how the bag of diamonds and then
once everything was over it ya like this
big-ass [ __ ] airing ship is just like
dig is heroin and I was like anybody
close the iris and respected
know me so my goal is to get like a five
so my final ascension
one of the greatest things that I ever
purchased on myself
41 millimeter Rolex presidential Rolex I
bought this for myself when I got when I
went shopping in platinum 2015 in
December this shipment of plenty of
phases went to diamonds and no diamonds
no diamonds diamonds diamonds and then
eventually when I got the human that I
just showed you guys earlier once I got
the diamonds out of there after six time
is out and this became like my everyday
peer like kind of just oh this in my
bookbag
my shot got this [ __ ] everywhere and
this was at the time I was a $55,000
this is like definitely one of my oldest
and one of my various pieces so this is
the so true that's not going to be
essentially for my son squad
[Music]